was your father a big inspiration on you
I mean you gave her a very different
sort of background my dad was a
basically a hustler that emigrated this
country like 1963 and I don't understand
or believe any of the stories I mean
real shady stuff you taught me one thing
well I say this all the time and I was
like he taught me a lot of things one of
which was like always work work work and
now he's like oh you're working too much
but in a nutshell this isn't this is Joe
Chang my dad we would go to restaurants
all the time as a kid because he worked
in restaurants for 30 years and he would
always look at the bathrooms whether it
was a fancy restaurant or more often
than not hole in the walls he'd always
come back from the bathroom me like okay
we can eat here what is so embarrassing
but for someone that cleaned toilets for
most of his life and restaurants it was
something that was very important to him
he's told him volumes about the
establishment let's just say you got a
hole in wall restaurant and you look at
the bathroom and they serve great food
or maybe that like their mom-and-pop
shop and they're just there doing
everything they're fighting the good
fight and you look in the bathroom and
it looks dirty from a distance but if
you look closer it's only looking dirty
because it's so worn in because they
cleaned it so much and then the key is
are they clean in the back of the toilet
because who cares about that who's
cleaning the toilet literally on the
totem pole the lowest person right but
if they're caring about that
it's rest assured that everything will
be taken care of I've gone to a fancy
restaurant try my dad's theory out
numerous times and it's worked out like
I've gone to arguably like the best
restaurant in New York City and you look
at the back of the toilet everything
else is looks spotless it is spotless
but if you look at the back of the
toilet where people would never clean
it's filthy and I think that tells you
volumes about that establishment you
know if I have the lowest person on the
totem pole caring about doing it the
right way I mean then we're doing it
right you have to have the people
believe that everything has to be right
and it's a battle to like find the
details
you know like a great meal is a
combination of all the small things that
no one else cares about
you